hi everyone my name is Julia I'm a
program manager on the visual C++ team
at Microsoft I focus specifically on the
vs code C++ extension thank you for
joining my session today I'm really
excited to talk about how to use vs code
for C++ development so let's go ahead
and get started so I'll start by going
over the topics that I'm going to talk
about today one thing is I want to show
you the things that you can do with vs
code the beauty of vs code is that you
can customize it to use it however you'd
like
whether that is strictly as a
lightweight text editor or as a full IDE
with built in debug support there are
also a bunch of non C++ specific
features that Thea's code has such as
the remote development extensions and
the live share extensions so I'm going
to talk a little bit about those today
as well I will also talk about which
tools we recommend for cross-platform
development in BS code cross-platform
development is a super popular scenario
these days and vs code is a great option
for that because it can be run on Linux
Windows and Mac OS I will also talk
about VC package today which is an open
source cross-platform c++ package
manager
it is consistently reported that package
management is a huge pain point for C++
developers we see this in the Stack
Overflow survey results the ISO CPP
survey results and more so I want to
show you how you can use VC package to
make managing your project dependencies
easier across all platforms VC package
also can be integrated with PS code
which we will go over in the demo this
part of the demo also includes a preview
of an exciting new feature it has not
officially been released yet so I'm
going to show you what we have in the
works and you can get a feel of what's
coming next with VC
package and some enhancements you can
expect to see in the near future so
let's talk about the things that you can
do with BS code as I mentioned it's up
to you how extensive you want your BS
code experience to be if you prefer to
use it strictly as a lightweight text
editor and take care of your building
and debugging outside of es code that
works if you would like to use it as a
full IDE it can do that too vs code has
great C++ language support it has
intellisense code completion a bunch of
productivity features such as find all
references renamed go to definition and
more you can build and debug your C++
projects in vs code it will find
whichever compiler debugger you have
installed on your machine we also have
native C make project support in vs code
as we recently started maintaining the C
make tools extension C make is one of
the most popular build systems for C++
projects especially for open source
projects and the C make tools extension
makes it super easy to configure C make
projects in vs code vs code has great
remote development extensions as well
this includes the SSH extension the
containers extension and the wsl
extension which is windows subsystem for
linux finally I'll talk about the
collaborative development features of BS
code vs code has a live share extension
pack which enables you to start a
collaborative session from vs code share
the URL to that session with anyone that
you trust and then they can join that
session from their instance of BS code
on their machine and you can work
together you can even do a collaborative
debugging session alright so for my
demos today I'm going to use the super
tux project it is an open source classic
2d game you can clone the github
repository which is what I did and super
text has a great community of developers
that
contribute new levels to the game so
it's a great open source project for
demos because it is cross-platform
alright let's get started alright so I
have my super tux project open in vs
code on my laptop right now and I'm
going to show you some of the cool C++
language features that we have in BS
code so let's start with the final
references I want to find all references
of this end state variable here and my
bad guy header file so I can just do a
right-click and then select find all
references or you can do shift el f12 if
you prefer to use a keyboard shortcut
and this will find both confirmed and
not confirmed references for this
variable so a confirmed reference means
it's not only a text match it's also a
semantic match and non confirmed
references mean it's a text match but it
might not be a semantic match it could
be in a comment in a string and an
inactive code block etc so here you can
see in this references pane on the left
in the top section these are all of my
confirmed results and down here these
are other references results that cannot
be confirmed so now let's do a rename so
let's say I want to rename this variable
to X state so I can again do a
right-click and then select rename
symbol from the context menu or I can
simply click f2 which will prompt me to
rename the variable all right so I'm
gonna type in X state but I want to
preview all of these changes before
committing them so I'm gonna do shift
enter to preview and again this is doing
a find all references before showing me
the references that will be renamed
cool so in this refactor preview tab I
can look at all of the references that
are candidates for my rename and select
which ones I want to include or exclude
in my changes so let's go ahead and go
through these and then once once you
feel good about the changes that you are
committing you can just select this
check mark right here to apply
refactoring all right so now I'll show
you go to definition go back to my files
all right so let's say I want to know
where this set flip function is defined
so I will do a right-click and select go
to definition or you can just do f12 for
the keyboard shortcut and you can also
go to declaration so I will show you
that as well and this should take me to
the header file there we go
it's also worth calling out that if you
want to see the definition or the
declaration but you don't want to
actually navigate to a new file then you
can use the peek capability by doing
control click selecting peek from the
contents context menu and then let's do
peek definition there we go so this
gives me a little preview of where this
is defined without actually taking me to
that file alright so now that you've
seen some of the core C++ language
features in vs code let's talk a bit
about cross-platform development
cross-platform development is super
popular these days
we see in a lot of survey feedback that
people are developing for more than what
platform they are developing for a
platform that is different from their
host OS and vs code is a great option
for both of those scenarios it runs on
Linux windows and
go s as I mentioned before it has native
support for C make and C make is a
cross-platform meta build system and
because V s code has such great support
for C make projects you can have your C
make project as a cross-platform project
and configure on BS code regardless of
what OS you're using vs code also
integrates well with VC package and we
see package works across all platforms
as well so if you're using C make and
you're using VC package in your project
that sets you up to be able to configure
your project easily in vs code across
Windows Linux and Mac also vs code
enables targeting different platforms
through remote development extensions I
briefly mentioned these before but
there's the SSH extension the containers
extension and the windows subsystem for
linux extension in today's demo I am
going to show you how to use the C make
tools extension to configure build and
debug your C make projects I will show
you how I've integrated VC package with
C make tools extension to manage all of
super tux's dependencies and I will then
use the remote SSH extension to SSH into
my Linux VM and show you that we can
configure everything following the same
exact steps on Linux and it just works
it'll use GCC and gdb but all of the
steps that you'll take to configure and
build your project are exactly the same
the CMAC tools extension makes it very
easy to configure CMake projects in vs
code you can create a new seeming
project from scratch you can turn an
existing project into a CMake project or
you can configure an existing CM a
project in other words if your project
doesn't already have a seeming list.txt
this extension will create one for you
if it does have one the extension will
find it and use it so this project super
tux already has a cmakelists exe so
let's just go ahead and start
configuring the project there are two
things that we need to do to configure
this project using CMake tools
the first is select a kit a kit contains
the project agnostic configuration
agnostic build instructions for your
code such as the name of the compiler
that you're using so at the bottom of
the screen and the blue status bar
you'll see the no active kit button I
can go ahead and click that and I see an
option of kits that I can use the first
time you do this you'll have to click
scan for kits which will search for
compilers on your computer it'll search
the path environment variable it'll look
for visual studio instances if for some
reason after scanning for kits the
compiler you want to use is not showing
up you can actually edit this see make
its JSON file directly and add it
yourself
so I've already scanned for kids which
is why you see a list of compilers on my
computer so I'm going to select the one
that I want to use you can see it's
loading the kit great it's loaded the
second thing I need to do is select a
variant these are instructions for how
to build the project so by default C
make tools extension will show you four
variants that you can use each
corresponding to a default build type so
I click right here we can see what they
are so I'm going to select debug and now
it is configuring my project all right
so now that our project has been
successfully configured
our build files have been written to
this new build folder in our project
directory so right here super tux build
you can see it in the left build folder
and these are the files that see make
tools generated for us so now we can go
ahead and build our project so one thing
we can do is select which targets we'd
like to build so if we select this
button here at the bottom that says all
you'll see a list of targets I'm going
to select all so we can go ahead and
build by just clicking that command in
the blue status bar
it's also worth calling out that all of
these commands in the blue status bar
that are provided by the C make tools
extension can be invoked from the
command palette so if you just do ctrl
shift P to open the command palette and
then type C make you'll see all of the C
make tools extension commands right here
all right so we have a successful build
now we can debug so you see I set a
breakpoint in the main dot CPP file and
down here at the bottom we can select
the target to lunch which we have as
Supra text to and we can just click to
bug and it will start the debugger we
can also click on the C make tab on the
left and you'll see your C make target
here as well super text too and you can
right click and select a bug from this
context menu as well
all right so now we have launched the
debugger and you can see it's stopping
at the breakpoint that I set and on the
left in the debugger panel we show the
values of local variables of registers
you can add a watch variable which is a
variable whose value you want to watch
change over time we show the call stack
and the list of breakpoints so you can
disable breakpoints directly from here
you can add a new breakpoint type the
name of the function you want to break
at and there you go so I'm gonna disable
this breakpoint I'm going to continue uh
stepping over and finish running the
program and our super tux GUI should
lunch and there it is I'll just take a
moment all right so there we have our
game so we just successfully built and
run super tux and vs code using the C
make tools extension and those are the
general steps for configuring a seeming
project in vs code so now let's take it
one step further and look at how we
integrated VC package with CMake tools
to manage all of super tucson's
dependencies so first I'll give you a
little bit of information about EC
package VC package is a cross-platform
command-line package manager for C++
there are over 1,300 libraries supported
in the VC package catalog across Windows
Mac and Linux it is open source and
there are a bunch of benefits to using
VC package to manage your C++ packages
first is it simplifies the acquisition
and installation of third-party
libraries all you need to do is run VC
package install and then the name of the
library from the
command line also the libraries are all
routinely tested against each other for
compatibility to ensure a high quality
catalog the last thing I'll mention is
that you can integrate C make with BC
package so that C make can find all
packages that were installed through
that instance of BC package when
configuring and building your project
installing Beauty package is very simple
and it is the same experience on Linux
Mac and Windows the first thing you'll
do is clone the github repository and
see the link in the slide then you run
the bootstrapper in the vc package root
folder and finally you can run vc
package integrate install to integrate
vc package with Visual Studio and BS
code so let's take a look at how this
works with super tux alright so as I
mentioned in the slides once you clone
the VC package github repository and
bootstrap it you can run vc package and
a great installed in a great VC package
with PS code so let me show you what
that looks like at my terminal I'm going
to navigate to the instance of vc
package that I'd like to use and I'm
going to run vc package integrate
install so now this integrates vc
package this specific instance of vc
package with PS code so that vs code can
use it for configuring intellisense for
source files it also tells you what you
need to set the C make toolchain file
path to be such that C May can find the
packages installed with this instance of
VC package by invoking the find packages
command so in order to hook this up with
the C make tools extension we just need
to edit the C make tool chain file
property for the C make tools extension
and we can do that in the workspace
settings JSON so the workspace settings
JSON lives in a dot PS code folder for
your project if you don't see it that
just means you haven't configured any
workspace specific settings yet and you
can get there from the command palette
so let's do control shift Pete
typing preferences open workspace
settings so this opens a UI where you
can edit settings for your workspace you
can also edit settings at the user level
and you can edit settings specific to
the extensions that you're using so
we're interested in the seeming tools
configuration settings so some of these
settings you can edit directly in the UI
others you'll see it'll tell you to edit
in settings on JSON so that's what we
did in order to set the C make toolchain
file path so I can show you that here we
go so you make configure settings so I
just clicked edit in settings JSON and
it created this C make configure
settings object whereas I specified this
emic toolchain file path and I added the
VC package build property and marked it
as on
so how VC package works today is
customers have to manually install all
of their project dependencies using VC
package and configure them so that C
make can find them we're working on a
new feature which we are very excited
about and it has not officially been
released yet but I'm going to demo what
we currently have in the works right now
so you can get a feel of where a PC
package is heading and some enhancements
that are coming soon so this new feature
is a manifest file and in your project
folder so a VC package JSON file that
lists all of your project dependencies
and then bc package will detect that VC
package JSON file and take care of
installing all of the listed
dependencies any dependencies that those
libraries have and configuring them so
that C make can find them all
automatically
I'll show you what that looks like so we
have this VC package JSON file for super
attacks so these are all of the
dependencies that super attack size and
so yes PC package is excited a you would
have to go in and manually install these
PC package install each of these
packages but the new experience is that
from your project directory so let me
navigate to my project directory I can
call VC package so install my triplet as
x64 windows specify binary caching so
what this will do is it'll find that VC
package JSON file that manifest file in
my super tux project and it will go
ahead and install all of these
dependencies if they're not already
installed and configure them so that see
make can find these packages so let's
click enter there we go so all of these
packages were already installed which is
why I was able to successfully configure
and build the project earlier on in the
demo but just to show you how this works
let's add in another item to our
dependencies list that I don't already
have installed ok so now if we run this
command again there we see that it
builds the FMT package and it's using
the cached binary package which makes it
faster and installs it and yeah it's as
easy as that so this is a really great
new feature that we're excited about
because it makes it really easy to just
share this manifest file in your project
and then anyone who's using this project
can just run the VC package command from
their command line and it will take care
of installing all the dependencies and
configuring them with CMake it's a very
automated seamless experience and very
excited about it so I want to reiterate
that one of the benefits of using vs
code and see make npc package is that it
allows you to configure your project in
a way that switching to a different
platform is seamless all of these tools
work across Windows Linux and Mac so I
just showed you how it works on Windows
now I'm going to use the vs code remote
SSH extension to SSH into my Linux VM
and show you that it works the same on
Linux I'm going to show you how to use
the remote SSH extension in vs code to
connect to a Linux VM so the first thing
you'll have to do is install the remote
SSH extension from the extension
marketplace once you do that then you'll
see this remote Explorer icon on the
left so if I click on that then I'm
presented with a list of ssh targets
that i have previously connected to
through this remote ssh extension in
this drop-down i can select between ssh
WS l vs online containers these are all
different remote extensions in vs code
and if you download the remote extension
pack then it will include all of these
extensions with it so I'm going to
connect to this host right here I could
also add a new one by clicking on this
plus sign but this one down here this is
where my super tucks project is let's
open a new window
all right and you can tell that you are
in your remote window based off of this
SSH target IP address in the bottom
green corner all right so let's open a
folder and it's important to call out
that the remote SSH extension and BS
code works differently than remote
development and visual studio because
all of my source files are already on my
Linux VM nothing is copied over from my
Windows laptop so before this demo I had
connected to the Linux VM and closed the
super tux github repository so let's
open that
all right there we go and you can see
that intellisense
is working properly on my linux again so
we can start by making sure that all of
the project dependencies are installed
on this VN by running the vc package
install command it has the vc package
JSON manifest file right here let's all
the dependencies so all we need to do is
run this command you see package install
binary caching from my project folder
and there we go all of these packages
are installed so then we can just follow
the same steps to configure the project
using C make tools you'll notice that
when I select a kit these are all
compilers that are found on my Linux VM
so this time I am using GCC so let's
configure and then we can build and we
can debug and this time it'll use gdb
which you can see right there executing
gdb alright so there we have it it's all
working properly on Linux followed the
same exact steps that I did on Windows
except that it's using GCC and gdb under
the hood so now you've seen how to
successfully use vs code the C make
tools extension and VC package to
configure our super tux emic project on
all platforms the takeaways from this
demo are that vs code C make tools
extension and VC package are all tools
that we recommend to ease your
cross-platform development experiences
additionally you should use the vs code
remote extensions if you would like to
develop for platforms
other than your host OS so now I'm going
to dive into how vias code can be used
for collaborative development vs code
has a live share extension pack which
enables you to start live collaboration
sessions directly in vs code directly in
that text editor so it makes it really
easy for you and your teammate to
quickly collaborate on the same code
base because you don't have to worry
about replicating code or adjusting
configuration or environment settings
what happens is that your teammate
actually sees a context of your
workspace in their editor and they get
all of the language features such as
intellisense and got a definition rename
and so on so once you are both in the
same collaborative session you can both
open files and navigate through the code
make changes and these changes will be
reflected in real-time for both of you
and you can even do collaborative
debugging sessions so you can both
independently use the debugger features
such as setting breakpoints or watching
local variables so now I will give you a
little demo of how the live share
extension works it's worth calling out
that normally it wouldn't be the same
person joining the session from their
computer and their VM you would use this
with a co-worker or a class member or
anyone that you trust but it could be it
could be any two machines right so in
this in this demo I will be using both
of the machines but if you're using this
extension it would likely be your
computer and someone else's computer so
on the my Windows laptop I'm going to
start my collaboration session and
before recording this demo all I did was
install the live share extension pack on
both my laptop and my VM if the
extension pack has any OS specific
dependencies that aren't already
installed on your machine feeis code
will let you know and will give you the
option to let it just install those for
you and take care
everything so on my Windows laptop I
will click on this live share icon on
the left to open this live share pain
and then I can click a start
collaboration session and this will give
me a URL that I can share with whoever I
want and by using that URL they can join
the session from their own device
alright so the invitation link has been
copied to my clipboard so now I'm going
to go onto my VM and in the same live
share pane on the Left I'm going to
click join collaboration session and
then paste the URL for the session that
I just started okay so this is just
joining the live session from my VM it
might take a moment since I'm doing this
remotely
there we go so now you can see in my
Explorer on the Linux VM I have this
visual studio live share workspace and
it is loading the super tux project from
the collaborative session that I started
on my Windows laptop so now I can
actually see the cursor of where the
other person in the collaborative
session is and if I highlight something
it will show up on that other person
screen they'll be able to see how I'm
interacting with the code let's say we
want to debug something together I can
start a debugging session so let's do
that I'm just I have my breakpoints set
in main I will click debug
and you can see it launch the debugger
in both my windows laptop and my Linux
we have so here I can debug with my
coworker directly from my own instance
of BS code as we wrap up our session
today I want to talk a little bit about
what's coming next for VC package and
for the C++ extension in vs code so
there are a few enhancements that we're
currently working on for VC package the
first is support for a manifest file
which is the VC package JSON that I
demoed for you today we're also working
on a first-class experience for managing
private libraries with VC package
customers will also be able to bring in
additional libraries outside of what
supported in the catalog VC package will
use binaries to update rather than
pulling from source every time and we
also will support versioning which means
you can specify exactly which version of
a package you would like to use so if
your project has a dependency on an
older version of a package that's fine
you'll be able to use that as for the
C++ extension we're currently working on
support for Linux on arm and arm 64
devices we'll start by releasing
intellisense modes for cross compiling
and then we'll have the full remote
development and debugging on the arm
experience if you are interested in when
these features are being released you
can stay tuned to the C++ team blog as I
said these are things that we are
currently working on and planning for so
I don't have specific dates to give you
today so the best thing you can do is
check the C++ team blog for
announcements of new features and that
is the link to the blog in the slide
also please give us your feedback the
C++ extension the C make tools extension
and VC package are all open source which
means you can find all of their repos on
github
we turn to our github repositories
frequently when we are creating our
roadmaps for new features we check out
the open issues pages on each of these
repos and see which open issues
have the most up boats and that tells us
what our customers care most about so I
have the links to the github repos on
the slide please if you have a bug or an
issue
check out the issues page and create an
issue if you don't already see the one
that you're looking for but feature asks
that you care about so we know what to
prioritize and of course feel free to
contribute to the repositories yourself
we are always looking for contributors
alright well thank you for coming to my
session and I'm excited to answer your
questions in the live Q&A